With up to 1,500 kilometers on just one tank of fuel,...
...the new M-Class is a real master of efficiency.
Compared to its predecessor,...
...the entire model range consumes an average of 25% less fuel.
The third generation M-Class has been revamped.
With the smallest turning circle in its market segment,...
...an ultra - modern engine lineup,...
...innovative assistance systems,...
...as well as both on and off-road capability.
The interior design concept means even more comfort.
On long road trips,...
...the spacious interior of the vehicle offers passengers the right comfort of a premium sedan.
Further improved safety in the new M-Class is provided by the familiar assistance systems from the S and E-Class.